so thank you for having me I'm happy to
be here today
I think I'll dive right in and really
start off by saying the work that I'll
talk about today is in what I'm largely
framing as digital civics and when I
talk about digital civics there's really
two things that I'm interested in here
and it's the intersection between what's
happening around smart cities and the
ways in which data and instrumentation
are starting to change how we think
about the way cities operate and the
kinds of information we can glean about
the infrastructures that we have whether
those infrastructures are physical like
the power grid or the transportation
system or whether those infrastructures
are kind of softer and about the people
and the residents that live in a city
I'm also interested in the ways in which
digital democracy are starting to come
in contact with this so thinking about
how technology is changing the ways in
which we interact with our systems of
governance on a local and national scale
but looking beyond just the moment of
kind of ritualized democratic
participation like voting and and more
the kind of everyday mundane
interactions that we have and how that
we and how we interact with the you know
municipal entities city agencies and
different institutions that that kind of
take place and take shape in our lives
across both of these I think the thing
that's important or the thing that's
shared is this idea of data right when I
think about data in the sense of digital
civics and in the sense of smart cities
I really do you think about a beach and
sand because when you go to the beach
you all often find that everything that
you encounter is also an encounter with
sand in some way right it's maybe the
warm soft feeling between your feet and
your toes or maybe it's that annoyance
of the the stuff that comes back home
with you and your bag or and you're in
your beach towel but no matter what the
sand is very much a part of the beach
and the same way that data is very much
a part of the smart City right is it is
the material of the of the thing the
other piece of this is participation
right and this is this is where the idea
of Digital democracy starts to ikan and
the ways in which that we participate
with each other with our community
whether that's showing up at a public
meeting and having a conversation about
the kinds of issues we care about and
you know rallying around issues that
that we want to have our elected
officials take action on I think we're
seeing a resurgence of this kind of
participation recently but when we bring
these together this idea that well if we
have data and we have participation then
we can construct and we can start to
build new kinds of cities and this idea
that these are our smart cities right
and that this is in fact what we can
have right if we take if we take the
material of the smart city and we apply
ourselves to it with care that we can
create these these very beautiful kind
of idyllic institutions and I've I like
this I mean I like sand castles sand
castles are very nice but the reality of
the smart city is more like this all
right
it's a bunch of silos of things that are
somewhat next to each other they're
often kind of crumbling perhaps not well
integrated right not the kind of
beautiful monolithic architecture that
we might imagine but also very
importantly they're always at risk of
being washed away by the tide all right
they're right the precarity of this
smart city is is very much a reality of
it right and so the challenge here is is
that thinking about local governments
even at the cities at the scale of a
city they're large and they're
ever-changing
right administration's come and go
different contracts with with outside
vendors for different services come and
go legacy systems are constantly in use
and so the challenge of actually making
use of the data making use of that sand
to create something new is always just
kind of lurking around and what we want
to do in thinking about digital civics
is looking at how do we take kind of the
the material that we have at hand and
the in the modes of participation that
we might encourage and create more
sustainable forms of organizations and
of interaction and participation that
enable us to move forward and solve some
of the pressing problems that cities are
facing today
so the the first thing that I would say
about this is in in some ways it's
really about thinking about thinking
through the challenges of different
forms of governance right not just about
deliberation and the mode of kind of
rational problem-solving right but but
thinking through the longer tail of
activities that happen after a moment of
deliberation say at a public meeting as
well as the activities that need to
happen beforehand as people prepare for
and become informed about different
issues and one of the challenges with in
HCI and with the kinds of work that I
think typically happens is it we've
there's a history of really looking at
this moment of deliberative action right
we've there's a legacy of systems that
look at how do we take computational
systems and other artifacts and help
people deliberate and understand an
issue understand the consequences of
decisions and work across different
kinds of community boundaries to really
you know work through a problem and come
to a solution but that's a really small
and in many ways privilege mode and it's
also very much tied to the kinds of
professional practices of public
administration right where the
challenges of safe fixing or dealing
with a transportation problem are put
into technical terms where it's about
understanding traffic flows and Road
widths and how do you operationalize and
optimize within that space the other
part of what what governance relies on
right is really fundamentally
participation right in how do people
come together and when do they come
together to actually be in the room and
work through the problem and then
certainly participation is necessary
within this mode of governance right and
it's something that I talk about in
another work when I when I work through
the kind of theoretical perspective of
public's and the ways that people
participate together to identify a
shared issue and then work through
different design processes to address
and respond to that issue but it's
through this this mode of participation
then that we can say well when people
come together in public meetings they're
identifying kind of the common good that
they want to work for I mean then
they're working collectively to try to
achieve that but again just as
governance requires participation
participation requires engagement
and an engagement is really about how do
you how do you motivate people right
what is that either incentive system or
what is the issue that gets people out
of bed to say okay something something's
up here that I need to address and if we
if we look at kind of HCI literature on
on systems that help with and work
within the Digital democracy space
they're very much focused on the kinds
of deliberative mode of working but if
we look at literature and community
engagement what they what they start to
point out is that in fact engagement
really only happens when a group of
people are identifying and responding to
an injustice right and that it's that
moment of almost a friction that becomes
the the cause for getting engaged all
right and this then becomes attention
and I think an interesting point of
where we might start to rethink both the
metaphors in the interfaces for the
kinds of interfaces we would build
around digital civics right so at the at
the end of governance is where we have
the kind of public administrator right
and and this is the person who's been
trained within a specific domain they
have very particular professional
practices often those practices are
around both framing a problem in a kind
of in a rational and technical way so
that it's something that they know when
there's a solution to it but then also
when it comes time to work with
communities and have the kind of public
participation activities these are built
around avoiding or at least tamping down
conflict right so the public meeting is
I think a great example where people
come together and can be very animated
but when it becomes very contentious
that meeting breaks down very quickly
and it gets shut down right and we have
plenty of examples from this past week
of how that's how conflict has been
avoided in these in these kinds of
public spaces this mode of conflict
avoidance is in fact like you know is
part of like their job right this is how
they do the thing that they're doing
they need to solve a problem they need
some public input and as they get that
public input they want to move through
to the next step right as anybody who
has a job to do and wants to go home at
5:00 p.m. to their family or to wherever
else they might be wanting to do
it's in some ways you can be very
sympathetic to that but an engaged
public they want conflict and if that
conflict is what gets them out of bed
and gets them participating and so what
scholars and community engagement have
really started to talk about is it well
this idea of deliberation and this idea
of persuasion which is another kind of
key piece in the way that some of us
think about these technologies that
those are actually kind of contra to
this idea of supporting engagement that
which you want you don't want persuasion
because an audience that is persuaded is
an audience that is disengaged right
it's being okay with the status quo in
some sense so then how do we think about
different modes of community engagement
and different systems that we might
build that take as a as an input or take
as a kind of way of being in the world
this notion of conflict and and
confronting injustice but then move it
through so that that that action is then
again legible to the professional side
where you're working with people who are
either elected or employed in local
governments so this is really the work
that I'm doing now and I'll I'll talk a
lot more specifically as I get into some
recent work that I've been doing with
the city of Atlanta but really to say
that community engagement is really
fundamental if we want to think about
digital civics and we want to think
about the Smart City as a place where
people and technology are participating
to create and of a new urban environment
right and that it's not just about
persuading people to use or to produce
data or to change their behaviors within
kind of regimes of sustainability and
environmentalism but really to say okay
how do we identify issues and help
people organize themselves around those
issues to take action and and do so in a
way that that isn't just about
deliberation so in October of last year
we launched with the city of Atlanta the
Atlanta community engagement playbook
this was a product of over 18 months of
work within the city of Atlanta to
rethink and rework at a city scale what
and community engagement meant both
across multiple departments within kind
of the mean
infrastructure of Atlanta but also
looking at the community organizations
neighborhood associations and how they
kind of come together right and thinking
about this mode what are the different
intersections of community engagement
across the city what precipitated this
was the construction of the new Falcon
stadium it's much further along now
today than then this picture that I have
for you the current one is the yes the
one at the top this so the new stadium
is next to the old stadium the old
stadium is on top of a pariah sorry a
prior stadium so since the 1970s there
have been three stadia built in this
community and what's happened is that
that the the neighborhood that the
stadiums are sited in is a historically
important traditionally black community
within Atlanta that is also very much
economically and physically distressed
so very low rates of owner occupancy
lots of vacant housing and many of the
kind of common and understandable social
ills that that follow poverty and
distress no matter where you are the
other thing that I think doesn't get
captured by this picture is that where
the stadium is sited is is on top of two
former african-american churches in
Atlanta one of which was the first
african-american Baptist Church in the
city so it's not just about being sited
in neighborhoods that are distressed and
also facing gentrification but that it
was also displacing kind of very
important cultural institutions within
those communities so as as this this
project was kind of coming to the fore
in 2014 when it really became clear that
it was going to happen and it was going
to happen here the community and the
city started to work through this idea
of how do we actually you know return
some benefit to the community and as
with many of these large kind of
projects there's something called a
community benefits agreement that gets
negotiated and typically these are these
are the kinds of agreements that say
that things like windfall employment
we return to the community some portion
of the local residents will be hired in
construction jobs or in vending jobs
following the opening that there'll be
job placement and training programs that
there might be some other kinds of built
environment changes so that the
construction would would have specific
requirements around traffic mitigation
or improved infrastructure for water and
sewage and this process really broke
down in the city of Atlanta and it broke
down and for for lots of reasons but I
think the result of that was that
decades of kind of erosion of
neighborhood you know trust and and kind
of faith within local government meant
that on both sides
there was just no there was no mode to
come together right and injustice was
seen everywhere and so there was there
was confrontation right and and with
with that confrontation meant that there
was no mode to come to this moment of
deliberation that would have enabled the
kind of outcome of a shared or you know
at least mutually agreed to agreement a
benefits plan sorry have any legal
rights here insensitive what was it do
they actually have any sort of
bargaining power
so the bargaining power they had was
through that churches so they didn't you
this this was the first time I think
ever in Atlanta's history that they
didn't use eminent domain to take the
land and the prior stadia as they did
the challenge was even though the the
challenge was the the churches that were
there institutionally that they burned
that the city purchased the land from
were actually serving diaspora for you
know people who used to live in the
community but we're coming back on
Sundays and it wasn't actually they
weren't actually serving the communities
directly but there was still this very
strong cultural identity to it and so
you know this becomes the complicated
history of kind of race and development
in Atlanta where the institutions that
kind of exists in some of the urban core
areas don't necessarily serve the
immediate neighborhood because that the
shifting demographics and the shifting
populations kind of over the over the
previous decades
so they did not have a lot of power
though their ability to stop or
forestall this process was very limited
and in the fracturing within the
community organizations or across the
community organizations about trying to
identify what what in fact that shared
goal was was a challenge which is partly
why we started with this process you
look at Facebook and its users or
mechanical turk in the workers it's sort
of like everything is essentially
eminent domain where it's like well
we're changing the platform right
and like what power do you actually have
to tap on this none really sytems well I
think this is why this this mode of
professional versus non-professional I
think is important because that the the
professional side of say public
administration where its technical
problem solving right is is very much
about well we're gonna we're going to
take these things and we're gonna we're
gonna bracket the kind of political
power struggles that go on and we're
just gonna focus on how do we up you
know optimize this thing whatever that
thing might be and the engagement piece
is really about those political and
power struggles and so how do you that's
the kind of transition like where these
modes of encounter happening and how do
you move between them for it's the power
struggle and then the power struggle
kind of turns into something that people
can then start to to work on together
yep and so to come back to where we were
the let's see where the the idea here
was that the city was provided or was
awarded a grant from an organization
called living cities to rethink
community engagement across the city and
really starting with and focusing on the
five neighborhoods directly around the
stadium and I really wanted to do what
we wanted to do was develop a community
led partnership to reestablish
meaningful engagement between the city
of Atlanta and the West Side
neighborhoods and there are four things
that we did to try to tackle this over
the course of 18 months so first was
really to understand the landscape who's
there that we wanted to understand what
were the engagement practices in the
city understand the the experiences of
being engaged within the community
and then to design some response having
having done that and so in understanding
the landscape really it was a period of
about six months to going around to
community meetings getting shouted out
of a few commissioning community
meetings and talking to people about
what's happening right so I think there
was an inclination at the beginning of
the project to go out and do an oral
history style intervention to say let's
collect stories from the from the
neighborhood to understand their history
and to preserve it with I think the
notion that if there's a fear of
gentrification and displacement that
doing some work to record and document
the history of the people that are there
becomes a way to you know palliative for
that fear but what we realized very
quickly was that other groups were doing
that already and they were doing it in a
very local and kind of internally
focused way that felt more authentic and
and coming in as kind of a
representative of the city in that mode
was very it was not productive and so
instead we step we took a step back and
said okay well who's here right who are
the key actors whether that's community
organizations different development
corporations different churches the
universities Georgia Tech as well as
kind of the Atlanta University Center
University so spell a Spelman Morehouse
Morehouse College of Medicine Clark and
really understand how are they working
together or not and how do we have a
conversation with each of those
stakeholders about what might come next
once we've done that we then started to
work more directly with community
members that we had identified through
different neighborhood associations and
we we trained a group of residents to do
interviews with city city officials and
employees and so over the kind of the
next I guess there's about three months
we had for community residents as well
as a couple of my graduate students go
out and interview close to 50 employees
of the city of Atlanta so from watershed
management to Parks and Recreation to
Public Safety through some of the
development organizations so really
looking at
what are the practices of community
engagement so when watershed management
says they do community engagement what
does that mean for them on a day to day
basis
right when Public Safety says that
they're doing community engagement what
does that mean and really trying to
understand the breadth of this practice
right in some cases community engagement
means simply we're going to print out a
flyer and we're going to stick it in
people's mailboxes all right we're going
to make it available at a public meeting
in other cases community engagement was
much more participatory where there was
a sense of we're bringing people into
the planning process as early as we can
and then we're providing opportunities
for that to continue throughout as the
plan develops right and the planning
department was in the midst of starting
to ramp up a master planning process in
the city of Atlanta so they were talking
about things in those terms this gave us
a really broad sense of what community
engagement is and how it works and what
we might want to do with it the other
piece of this was understanding the
experience of being engaged and so we
held a couple of workshops the first of
which was about a hundred and twenty
people showed up from the neighborhoods
and we ran through a series of exercises
to understand when they were engaged by
the city what was that like and what
would what was the city engaging them
with often it was about you know
infrastructure failures or other kinds
of service delivery breakdowns and that
being engaged was about trying to
address or redress those those service
breakdowns but it was also about the
kinds of routine modes of engagement
that happened through the kind of
official and institutional channels so
Atlanta has something called the
neighborhood planning unit it's a
collection of kind of geographic regions
in the city that are meant to be where
local decisions are made around zoning
and other planning and this is really
the primary kind of point of interface
between city governance and residents
where they come together and say well
either plans are presented or different
zoning decisions are made
and kind of presented to the community
for feedback and input in this case we
had a different set of community members
that we had trained so about ten and all
they went and interviewed a total of
about forty five other residents to
understand more broadly what's going on
in their neighborhood so to understand
both how does community engagement
happen and what does that experience
like right we had a total of about
eighty interviews across both kind of
sides of this done by community
residents so it wasn't you know just
kind of academics and scholars coming in
and say I'm gonna do this research
project but it was really about building
out this conversation with both city
employees and residents to understand
what this practice looks like and how it
unfolds and kind of in and affects
people's lives I think one of the really
important things that came out of this
was it as this design process move
forward and as the individuals we were
working with did these interviews they
started to really develop a sense of
empathy for how hard it is on both sides
and if looking back at the beginning
when we were getting shouted out of
community meetings one of the things
that would happen often is you know the
city needs to fix what they're doing
like one or the community needs to do
something better one side was blaming
the other for why it wasn't working but
then through this process we started to
essentially kind of cultivate a capacity
for empathy about how difficult
community engagement is anyway and then
build some advocacy within the community
that recognized that and was able to
talk to their own constituents to say no
actually it didn't work because of this
and but now that we know why it didn't
work we can start to understand how to
do it differently so following all that
in the middle of the kind of middle half
of the summer we began a 12-week very
intensive design process where we were
meeting at least once a week for usually
at least three hours at a time
with about 15 community members to
really talk about okay now that we
understand what's going on in terms of
community engagement on both sides how
do we address it how do we identify the
key breakdowns how do we then think
about strategies and techniques for
addressing those breakdowns and also how
do we understand and
what the that kind of the key
obligations and values are for what good
engagement looks like why does it matter
what should the outcome be you know how
do you how do you go and do that and
what we ended up with was this community
engagement playbook so this was released
in October as I mentioned and it's
really divided into two parts maybe
three parts so one part is kind of
general information about the city of
Atlanta so for for residents who may not
be familiar with kind of the governance
structure and how it works we have some
of that information but then there's a
set of plays that are really dedicated
to community organizations the
neighborhood associations the small kind
of issue focused nonprofits to say here
are the strategies and techniques that
you might deploy to mobile ought to
identify your constituency to mobilize
your base and then to do work going
forward right recognizing that there was
in some sense a gap in the capacities of
some of the local organizations where
some of them were very sophisticated and
been operating for a long time others
were just getting started and trying to
figure out how to do it but one of the
challenges that we saw kind of
universally was that coalition building
was very hard and some of that was for
structural reasons and that there was
very scarce resources and so a
willingness to work together was in some
ways not possible because there was
competition for those scarce resources
but by laying this out in the playbook
and saying here's what happens when you
start to work together and here's some
techniques for how you might do that
we're hoping to provide a set of tools
that enables that to happen differently
on the other side we had a set of plays
that were targeted at what we call
service providers mainly that was the
the city of Atlanta and the different
agencies that it that it contained but
it was also meant for kind of the large
third sector organisations that have
massive programming initiatives and in
those neighborhoods so something like
the Atlanta Community Food Bank who
already do really great work but they're
a nonprofit that operates there that we
wanted to have a way to speak to the
kinds of programs that they're doing in
the ways in which they kind of identify
and work with community partners
and what the what the playbook does I
think in the and the large-scale is it
provides a common framework and language
for understanding what community
engagement is and where the points of
intersection might be across these kind
of two sides of what's going on the
other thing that it does and why I think
it's important for HCI right so I've
come this far and I haven't talked about
technology yet is that it's it becomes a
map for thinking about these alternate
forms of interactions and interfaces
within the realm of digital civics that
are that are not about deliberation but
are about the work that has to happen to
bring a community together and to
mobilize and organize their efforts and
then the work that has happened on the
other side as city governments need to
recognize and understand how do you how
do you work within a place that has a
history and is trying to accomplish
goals it may be not immediately apparent
right and in thinking about the kind of
turnover that you get in public office
and also in kind of public sector work
this becomes important as a way to build
out that organizational history and
intelligence to say well we know we can
remember what was happening so this is
where I'm gonna try something different
because I was invited to try something
different I have some handouts and I
would like you all to work in smallish
groups I'll just not everyone needs once
I just like kind of take one and pass it
around
I'll break these up a little bit better
I want to make sure I get to the other
side I don't know if whichever size
clustering you might find appealing and
so what I would like to do is to start
to really think through all right I've
done this very clumsily make sure some
circulate back as well please so not
everyone needs one actually no more than
one per every five people let's say what
I'd like to do is to start thinking
through what are the different metaphors
that we might imagine when we talk about
Civic digital civic systems alright so
I'll put this up here as well so you can
see it so there are three columns of
things on each handout not every handout
is the same there's a column of apps or
services many of them familiar there's a
column of issues I was trying to draw on
things that were not necessarily
specific to Atlanta but I think
generally applicable and then there's a
column that is a selection of the kind
of categories of plays that I'm pulling
out of the PlayBook with a small
description and I would like to take I
don't know ten minutes or so for you all
it's a brainstorm around how do you
respond to the the sentence at the
bottom right so that the let's do this
right that the Instagram of diversity
enables us to co-create goals with
community members right by creating
narrative based civic interactions where
different people and groups can tell
their stories and develop empathy and
co-learning and so I admit I've had more
time to think about this so that's fine
what I want you to focus on is within
those apps or services it's not about
the application of that app kind of as
it is but what are the key kind of modes
of interaction or the key kind of system
attributes that that that that system or
app enables right so with Instagram it's
about sharing images right we could also
think about Bitcoin it's not necessarily
about economic exchange but maybe the
blockchain is actually that's the
concept that matters most here right and
so kind of taking apart the app or
service and thinking of it more as a
metaphor
rather than as a tool with a specific
shape and so if we take ten minutes I
will happily walk around and work with
talk through this with some of you and
then at the end of that will we'll do a
kind of a quick report back I'll have a
few other things to say and then we can
open up for some more questions
[Music]
Tina SH yes do you want me to leave I'll
put this one back up and if you would
like a different app or you have a
different issue you can fill in the
blank I just provided some as a way to
try and help bootstrap the activity
[Music]
I guess I mean
let's take a minute to reconvene there's
nothing oh it'll get some highlights
from from around the room about which of
your which of your responses would you
be willing to share and let's start over
here I'm gonna I'm gonna go across the
room so I know I've talked to at least
enough people around the room that there
are things too to share you can just you
know read out your sentence however you
would like okay
right around narrative and how that
narrative reflects communities not just
not just about kind of the humanities
yeah great yes enables us to narrate
together by creating a platform for
members to share their story and create
a sense of shared expansively thank you
maybe yes I know that's so another
narrative one but thinking about I think
brings together or brings forward this
idea of empathy and how do we think
about building empathy through the
system's right not just solving the
problem of immigration yeah over here is
for the video of living which enables us
to collect data by creating a common
platform where they can share
information about mm-hmm okay
yeah I'm imagine yes I like this idea of
a living wage it's contingent kind of
algorithmically based on on current
conditions so
you might be making more or less money
depending on what's going on so I mean
clearly this is meant to be a kind of
somewhat silly somewhat uncomfortable
exercise and thinking through the kinds
of metaphors that we have with the
systems that we know and recognize but
then what does that look is what does
that look like as we as we turn and move
towards other kinds of outcomes right so
none of these systems were really
designed for the kinds of civic outcomes
and the kinds of goals that might be
described here but just as as I think
work in HCI say has tended towards
thinking about deliberation because
deliberation is done in forums and it's
done in the kinds of systems that we
know how to build in some way and so
trying to take what we know how to build
and apply it in a civic mode becomes a
natural reflex if we take the kinds of
systems that we know how to build like
these kinds of apps and these kinds of
crowdsourcing or distributed platforms
and very carefully think about why these
metaphors matter and how do we change
the way that we apply those different
metaphors so I think the implications
for some of this when we think about
different kinds of Civic technologies is
really focusing in on what are the
encounters of civics how do people come
to it is it through the public meeting
or not is it through voting or not is it
through the Community Association
meeting is it the way you know is it
sitting on the porch with your neighbors
and talking and at the end of the day
right and also looking at the
professional side within municipal
agencies and across them alright so are
the practices that happen say and the
Planning Department compatible with and
or at least aware of the practices that
are happening in public safety and how
do those go in conversation with each
other the other is thinking about the
products that come out of this kind of
work and the kinds of systems that we
would build what are these interfaces
right I think at lunch we were talking
about how these kind of large
distributed systems and these social
computing platforms you know it's hard
to talk about them in a way that that
breaks them apart because they get black
box in a way that the interaction piece
is actually hidden away
that's where the meat of the of what
makes the system magic is and so how do
we start to unpack that and think about
it as an infrastructure for engagement
right not just a mode of decision-making
but really of being able to provide
affordances for people who are
confronting an injustice however they
might perceive it to be able to take
action on it and then finally thinking
about the kinds of social and technical
capacities that we might build within
communities and within cities right is
it about the the kind of social capital
of a neighborhood being able to marshal
the people and the assets that it has
within to take action or is it about a
set of institutional capabilities within
a department of city government that
needs to be able to go out and do the
work I'm kind of outside their office
and the kind of cubicle farm that they
might be living in and then also I think
about individual and collective modes
right is it about that person who shows
up and yells in the microphone for the
thing they want or is it about that
person who goes out and organizes their
neighbors and their community members to
get together to do something at the
scale that's that's bigger than an
individual and so these are the things
that I'm thinking about and these are
the kinds of challenges that I'm working
through very specifically in the context
of Atlanta and the community engagement
playbook moving beyond kind of
neighborhood scale interaction work and
thinking at the city scale but looking
at opportunities where we can can change
the metaphors and change the modes of
doing civics that are not just about
these modes of kind of privilege voting
or public meeting so I think I'll close
there and invite any more questions or
comments I'm happy to to talk through
this more thank you
[Applause]
yeah I'm curious do you specifically
start from a perspective to use almost
problematize the persuasion perspective
no but they're sort of like the
deliberative democracy literature and
all this like we want to start from
traditionally that different people want
to understand each other or want to come
to concoct some common consensus or are
in art are you more on on the other end
of that axis to true where it was more
about agitation in trying to it seems
like you know a lot of the HCI
literature has I would say lovely been
up on what on the other side where it's
like let's just you know regulation we
use it as a great example like like
Cornell like let's try to get people to
debate this stuff grab the conclusion
but I'd like at least the last few
months of indicating that there's like a
swing toward this sort of like agitation
based yeah we barking up the wrong tree
here I might say so yeah
I think so some of this work that I'm
doing also aligns with work that my
colleague Carl DeSalvo does around
adversarial design and I think he and I
share this this inclination to say well
yes a lot of the work in HCI has
traditionally looked at this mode of
deliberative democracy there's also a
kind of assumption of altruism in the
ways and the reasons why we would
participate that like as good yes as
good citizens this is of course what we
would do and I think it's it's worth
stepping back from that and saying well
no a lot of the work that happens and
not just now but even you know if we
look we can go back a long time and say
well where change starts to happen is
where this kind of agonism takes place
where people are contesting what's going
on because it's not serving their their
needs or their values or beliefs one of
the examples that I think is a good and
ready one is say roe v-- wade alright so
when that was initially passed by the
Supreme Court I think the the community
of people that were kind of pro-choice
said yeah the Supreme Court ruled we're
done
right but the people that did not
believe that and we're not satisfied
continue to contest that in different
ways right and over decades built up you
know a number of movements within the
states and then that is now probably
going to end up back at the national
scale national stage again right and so
this is a good example of where this
idea of deliberative democracy which I
think has its sense of yes once you once
you've deliberated and made a decision
then you move on to whatever the next
decision is is not in fact the case that
it's really about this constant
contestation that you're we're
constantly churning and actually that
churn is productive right it's move it's
it's it's never done but it's always
kind of in motion and that's the place
that we I think can focus on you know we
can also look at say the Occupy Wall
Street movement is another example of
this where it's about the churn right it
nothing was necessarily solved but but
things started to move I think the Tea
Party or other examples where that
agonism produce different kinds of
effects my PhD student maryam assad is
working on some of this and i think one
of the challenges is that there aren't
necessarily great assists like systems
that do it systems might get
appropriated in different ways to do
some of this work so we can look at the
way Occupy Wall Street use technology
particularly in their in the way that
network of people was mobilized in
response to Hurricane sandy or
superstorm sandy and that becomes an
interesting case study in the way that
some appropriation happened to help
action occur but I think one of the
arguments that Miriam makes very very
well is that that there aren't kind of
clearly purpose-built responses that
that look within this space it's always
been about this kind of moment of
appropriation and so to take seriously
this mode of kind of agonistic
contention means that we actually were
looking for different metaphors for how
we think about you know digital civics
and and democratic participation
anyone else want to rise up so we talked
about what you were just talking about
and how a lot of the Xterra systems have
been focusing more on deliberation and
supporting that kind of a thing I was
wondering do you have any theory of why
that is why do we have so many different
ways to deliberate and talk about the
fact that the problem exists but not as
many to move beyond that um so yes I
have some ideas some of them are maybe
more tongue-in-cheek than others but you
know I think one is is really down to
the kinds of maybe commitments or
perspectives that computer science has
had a Renault that kind of aspiration
that you know if if we want to think
about the world like were I think as a
field we're fairly optimistic and so we
think well we can go out and we want to
make change for the better and that
really the way that we do that is we
come together and we work through a
problem collectively we come to a
decision and that that's how that
happens I think the other is also
pragmatic and that the kinds of the
kinds of systems if you look at them
that support deliberation or kind of the
kinds of systems that naturally fit with
computing all right there they're about
sharing messages and it's about kind of
maybe uploading and downloading and you
know you might have some metrics or some
incentives that you're able to to kind
of operationalize within that system to
to take some empirical understanding of
whether it's effective or not and so you
know it becomes a you know chicken and
egg problem between well are we are we
solving this because it's the right
problem to solve or are we solving it
because we're interested in this space
and this is where we can at least
initially start to get traction to start
to understand how computing might unfold
here and I think it's you know it's a
little of of all of that I mean it's not
said you know I want to be careful it's
not to say disparage work that's been
done on deliberation but to just say
that there's a there are a number of
different metaphors and they're you know
if you look at just the the you know
political science of democracy there's a
lot kind of more to democracy than just
deliberative democracy
yeah yeah like a specific example the
kind of things that people talk about
with respect to the stadium what just
sure like a specific conversation so
specific conversations were around the
consequence of displacement so the
expectation the in the the city has said
very clearly that it wants to build lots
of hotels and other things around the
stadium which those hotels have to
displace housing that's already there
expectations that are built historically
so one of the I think one of the unusual
attributes of this project is that the
current stadium was built and I think it
opened in 92 if I have my dates right so
most of the residents remember the last
process where they came in and promised
positive impact and change with the
stadium that didn't materialize and so
now they're watching it happen again
so there's deep skepticism and so the
conversation is well last time you said
we were gonna get more jobs and we're
was going to be economic benefit for the
community and there was going to be you
know development that helped us and it
didn't happen and so now what's what's
going on now right it's also around
infrastructure so this particular
community geographically is in what's
called a bottoms area low-lying kind of
watershed in Atlanta historically it
followed the the rail line in Atlanta
and was also why it was a an
african-american black community kind of
going back in time and so it started off
as undesirable land that had you know
flooding problems it is still land that
has flooding problems and so this idea
that they're going to put massive
parking lots and hearts and permeable
surfaces in that are going to extend and
kind of exacerbate some of these just
infrastructure and you know physical
world issues we're also part of the
conversation
like where people have immunity like SAS
but at the end of the conversation
yes is the key the conversations not
over right the stadium is still being
finished and I think what's happened the
thing that's been satisfying is that
through this process of building the
PlayBook and then circulating this the
both the artifact itself the book that
we've created and into the neighborhoods
as well as the the story the account of
how it was produced has provided a
moment where this the residents are
saying okay we have something we can
work with and we also have something
that we can use to hold the city
accountable as we continue to work
through the specific changes that are
going to be coming and so it's not like
you know a project of this scale is
going to there's there's at least 10
years of ongoing development and change
that will happen within these
neighborhoods as hotels and other things
kind of crop up and so you know it's
it's never just a done thing again it
can be continually contested and so what
we've tried to what we've hoped to do
and we'll see over time is provide a set
of tools that will help communities and
the organizations that are there kind of
work the system in a way that that
benefits them and help them helps them
hold you know elected officials mostly
to account yeah all right let's take our
speaker one more time
you